Buddha's father is visited by an angel
who tells him that his son is going to
grow up to be the greatest temporal
profane ruler the world has ever seen or
a great spiritual leader and his father
being a pragmatic and conservative man
decides that there's no possible way I'm
going to allow my son to take the
ambivalent road of spiritual
enlightenment I'm going to allow him to
fall completely in love with the world
so that he will remain attached to his
domain
so prior to Buddha's birth his father
constructs a great city with walls
around it and inside that city he
removes all signs of pain frustration
and disappointment
any sign of ugliness feet and AIDS the
only people that are allowed to exist
within this city are those who are in
perfect mental and physical health who
are Paragons of beauty and virtue and
the idea that lurks behind that
archetypal story is that when a father
has a child the his moral obligation is
to shield the developing consciousness
of that child from contact with any of
the horrors of life that could provide
the child with an experience too
traumatic for that developing
consciousness to apprehend so because
it's an archetypal story it relates to
the development of all people not just
the redemptive Savior and that's the
motif that the Buddhist story initially
follows a good father makes his child
fall in love with life by enticing that
child into a direct relationship with
all that life has to offer so Buddha
grows up within this walled garden is
unselfconscious paradise but precisely
because he's being shielded to this
degree and allowed to mature his
consciousness continues to expand and
the world outside the boundaries that
his parents have established for him
starts to attract his attention now we
know already that the forbidden fruit
right the lure of what's outside the
walls is something that human beings
just can't keep their mangy little paws
off right we are absolutely
uncontrollably curious and the best way
to make sure that we
investigate something is to lay down a
stricture that says whatever you do
under whatever circumstances never look
there right and then the automatic
systems that underlie our orienting and
that motivate our seeking experience are
constantly pulling our attention
precisely to that forbidden spot
compelling us to investigate exactly
that which has been forbidden so because
Buddha is a consciousness developing in
a healthy manner he immediately becomes
curious about what lies beyond the the
limits that have been established with
him and he makes a decision to go
outside of paradise right which seems a
particularly ridiculous thing to do
given that in principle he has
everything he could possibly want inside
the walls but then again we have the
Troublesome notion of the original sin
of Adam right which is that if any of
you were offered a forbidden fruit again
under circumstances mythologically
equivalent to those that obtained in the
beginning you'd immediately reach your
hand out and take it because what we
haven't got for human beings is always
far more compelling than what we have
got so Buddha goes outside the walls but
his father who's a good father although
somewhat conservative decides he's gonna
rig the game a little bit so he gets rid
of everybody that's diseased or unhappy
or uncomfortable or ugly or old or
anything that could possibly disturb the
Buddha and he lines the streets with
flower waving women and puts petals on
the road and sends his son out in a
gilded chariot but the gods who are
lurking around right the troublemaking
gods who represent chaos and disorder in
the unknown decide to send in front of
Buddha a sick man who hobbles unsteadily
into view and Buddha asks his his
retainer precisely what this phenomena
represents and his retainer says well
you know human beings like you since
you're human are subject to the
deterioration of these their physical
powers in an arbitrary way and this man
is one person who's being so afflicted
and so Buddha is completely disenchanted
by his exploratory move out into the
terrible unknown and runs back into the
castle walls and shuts the door and is
perfectly happy to think of nothing for
months but then as his anxiety
habituates and his curiosity grows he
can't stand the notion of never going
outside the walls again and outside he
goes again and this time we're after his
father prepares the route ever so
carefully the godsend in sight an old
man who hobbles into view and Buddha
looks at him in shock and horror and
says to his retainer just precisely
what's going on here and his retainer
says well that's an old man and
everybody gets old and you're going to
get old too and that's the way of all
humanity and that's the point at which
Buddha's self-consciousness expands not
to only include the possibility of
degeneration but to include the temporal
horizon that's characteristic of life
and he finds that so terribly shocking
that he runs back into the castle and
shuts the walls down and plays with his
friends for another six months or maybe
a year till his anxiety finally
habituates and he goes out one final
time and this time the gods send a
funeral parade for him and he sees his
first dead body and
this is such a terrible shock to him
that he can't even go back to the castle
so his father prepares for him a great
party in the woods near the castle full
of nude dancing women who are perfectly
willing to flaunt themselves and to
offer themselves to him but Buddha is so
absolutely a catastrophic ilish arc by
this notion of emergent death that he
can't take any pleasure whatsoever and
what's being offered to him and he
leaves the kingdom once and for all and
you think well that's exactly what
happens to you when you grow up right if
you're reasonably well socialized and
properly looked after then your
curiosity gets the better of you and you
keep going out into the world until what
your parents have established for you is
no longer sufficient for you and as a
consequence of that movement own into
the world you find out all sorts of
things characteristic of your own life
that not only your parents can't
precisely explain to you but even the
broader formal structures of your
culture have a very difficult time
handling and when you finally do
encounter such realities and allow their
effect on you to fully manifest itself
well then you're finally independent and
you no longer can return home but from
that point forward you're also burdened
as Adam is burdened when he loses his
paradisal unselfconsciousness with the
full revelation of what it means to be
limited and alive so what happens to
Buddha as a consequence of this
revelation he becomes an apprentice and
The Chronicles of the Buddhist adventure
are careful to say that he becomes the
world's most proficient practitioner of
samkhya which was a philosophical
precursor to yoga and then to yoga so he
masters all the positions in the asanas
until he's disciplined physically to an
almost unlimited degree and then he
decides that he'll adopt a stance of
world renunciation which is also
something he's remarkably good at and he
starves himself until the chroniclers
say he resembles nothing so much as a
pile of dust and then having exhausted
all the disciplinary structures that his
sophisticated culture has to offer him
but still not precisely finding the
answer that he's looking for he retreats
into the forest place of the unknown
and sits himself at the base of a tree
underneath the tree he's visited by
visions and temptations the first vision
is an essentially erotic one life itself
tempts him back out of his
self-conscious state into the domain of
pure physical pleasure a perfectly
reasonable temptation right and one
that's powerful enough so that Hindu
philosophers say be as their churches
and cathedrals are covered with erotic
drawings if you can't get past the
erotic drawings into the church that's
the domain that you should still inhabit
right in the dawning phases of life at
least till middle age that's the
appropriate mode of being to be enticed
and seduced by the physical pleasures
that life has to offer but in the final
analysis those are not sufficient to
solve the problem of emergent
self-consciousness and so the angel of
death visits him and offers him the
opportunity to exist permanently in a
state of Nirvana
a very very interesting twist on the
story because you have to wonder given
the association say between suicidality
and the notion of paradise that exists
underneath that if what Buddha isn't
being offered by the angel of death is
in fact death and the cessation of all
the problems of being regardless he
rejects that attains enlightenment
briefly and then decides to return to
the world to share what he's discovered
with all of suffering humanity the idea
being that the Buddha who is the
awakened or enlightened one is capable
of attaining a transcendent state but
also knows fully that because human
beings have a shared social aspect it is
not possible for any one person to
attain Redemption until all people
attain Redemption the reason being that
it's very difficult to be transcendent
and enlightened when you see someone
who's sick lying in a ditch
[Music]